the idea that you could enumerate all
the different flows on the the free and
open internet of technical data related
to guns not just enumerate them but
somehow license and control these flows
is a hallucination of
power what does Cody Wilson founder of
Defense distributed the company
responsible for the world's first 3D
printed gun really want and how close is
he to achieving it that's the subject of
filmmaker Jessica su's new feature
documentary death athletic a dissident
architecture suce followed Wilson for 7
years as he grew the world's most famous
DIY Gun Company prevented multiple
lawsuits from shutting it down faced his
own personal legal troubles around a sex
case and established himself as the
leading voice and practitioner of crypto
anarchism Wilson was also a character in
su's first documentary no control which
came out in
2015 I was deeply interested in all
things technopolitics at that time and
my proximity to his work uh made me want
to continue telling his story but
specifically I wanted to create a
documentary that wasn't going to be a
two-minute piece um I wanted to explore
the Mischief I wanted to explore
the motivations the ideals um the ethics
and morals which is something that
nobody had really tapped into um and
see see where the film would go but not
um not really knowing how long that
would take I mean unconsciously I knew
that this was going to be a long journey
but I don't think anyone consciously
sets them up for such a long journey
because uh that's a difficult pill to
swallow but um I wanted to create
something that was you could say a
historical moment
captured that's so that was that was
turned into an obsession of watching the
story
unravel you mentioned the Mischief
that's really one of the defining
characteristics of Cody's Persona he's a
mischievous prankster uh he described it
himself in an interview that you
conducted with him
alongside alongside Benjamin Denio the
co-founder of Defense
distributed we knew of each other during
undergrad I think but we didn't start to
collaborate until we became Facebook
friends that's true and that was a
process of basically engaging in back
and forth [__] posting with a bunch of
lip progs New World Order liberals right
like uh yeah so you bonded over trolling
that's right that's exact we Bond over
trolling well and we're still bonding
today we just trolling bigger targets
now bigger marks huh so what is the role
of trolling for Cody Wilson in achieving
his political objectives oh interesting
um
trolling perhaps at the beginning of his
career we could say was more I think a
literal troll filled with mischief and
uncertainty of where things would go but
that same kind of aspiration and
inspiration he says turned into trolling
bigger marks right and learning the
power of the symbolic turning that into
something that was real that was you
know in the court system that had very
strong abilities to kind of change
change not only law but change the the
principles of of how things were going
to be described and organized as first
amendment and second amendment issues of
code yeah trolling is I think is is
still a strong I don't know how to say
this but um a strong part of what Cody
does but he doesn't do it effortlessly
or without forethought or without
knowing where he's going with it there
there is there is uh there's meat behind
what he's doing there's one part where
he talks about himself in Silicon Valley
terms as a disruptor people want to talk
about disruption all the time or
disrupting industry well look here's a
big Target and no one's trying to hop
that razor wire fence over there in
Virginia no one's trying to get at the
[Music]
mic well look we're here as basically
ideological
[Music]
enemies I'm trying to at least be able
to say
I fought it you know I fought as far as
I could and I made them earn it you know
and I made them stand there and say no
we control the internet and we control
you he rose a Fame as like the 3D
printed gun guy but this clearly is not
just about making guns because guns are
fun and cool or for hunting or even just
self-defense what is your larger
understanding of Cody's objectives it's
technopolitics in action which most
people don't understand report on it's
really uh forcing processes of
democratic Solutions onto stages where
most people have huge debates and issues
so specifically the gun um it's
releasing it on the internet um once
it's there as we all know it can't be
taken off um it's kind of like the
Democratic distribution of information
um and from there the statement becomes
one
of not just Anarchy but of um who gets
to control so it's a demonstration
of the inability of governments in this
digital age to actually have utility in
their idea of controlling and
surveilling everything we see this in
all digital Technologies from computer
to Bitcoin to anything on anything in
the crypto space I think technopolitics
is also the idea that technology is
outpacing
politics there is um technology that can
be critical it forces politics that are
kind of aged and ancient and not caught
up in this time frame of the digital
world to catch up and in doing so it
shows its face of control and the desire
of surveillance there's another part of
the documentary that reminds me of what
you're talking about right now where
Cody talks about the gun as a way to
express your political will as an sort
of an alternative way to
vote guns are still important because
politics is still
important see what I'm saying there is
uh not that other people's different
politics are important but the fact that
like Politics as an idea is still
important and guns are a certain
admission of the reality of the
[Music]
political the threat of the use of
violence that's power that's political
power if you can download this and use
this your vote means a little bit more
or indeed you have a different kind of
vote what I've probably come to realize
far more is that the threat of guns is
actually more quote unquote dangerous to
governments than maybe specifically in
the United States than um the actual
having of them because they're they're
everywhere in the US the fact that we
have these like oh like these uh debates
and conversations of like just taking
little Parts off of guns and everything
when there's like hundreds of millions
and lots of people know how to make
these little pieces that they're trying
to you know Outlaw um
so I think definitely what Chang over
these last 10 years regarding the
politics of guns was how ineffective
they actually are and how they don't
really reflect a large majority of the
people they're trying
to um govern if you will yeah and I know
that behind the defense distributed
headquarters they've got a little
gravestone that has gun control em
blazed on it so that's their idea is gun
control is dead we we killed it in
America you know guns are so tied to
American political culture but of course
they have use out they have political
use outside of our borders and you had a
whole segment that was devoted to that
idea like the Freedom Fighters we are we
thought to ourselves you know what we're
going to do it we're going to try to
take up the mantle the whole idea of of
our work is to enable the everyday
common man around the world wherever he
may be to produce entire Firearms the
shift from symbolic to
practical you reach a point in being
proun where you stop caring about the
Second Amendment and you realize that
being armed is a human right every part
in the assembly can be purchased in
Europe or can be ordered from China
almost as easy if not easier than Ikea
[Music]
furniture
people are building FTC Nets in Brazil
in New Zealand in Australia everywhere
and they're posting pictures and videos
there and people are sharing their ideas
and gun control is [__] dead a lot of
things Cody was doing at the beginning
were you know performance art in a way
those are my words right they were
symbolic they were um they were to
really RI like get people riled up and
understand that we were entering a new
era of like digital performance if you
will and at that point there was a lot
of other creators Engineers makers that
started putting their Creations online
in a far more visible fashion and even
though it's still a pretty Niche uh
environment it definitely has exploded
with different groups and different kind
of like known figures and YouTube
channels and we'll see how long those
channels stay up so Cody Wilson
launched this movement with his mixture
of
Showmanship
trolling his legal knowledge it's clear
to me both from the film and my
conversations with him that getting
jumping into these legal fights are kind
of what gets him up in the morning and
gets him going um and these legal cases
reach far beyond guns there's a part
where his attorney Alan gura talks about
what a rule
against defense distributed would really
mean the government had a really hard
time explaining the most basic issue
here in the case how do people create
information and release it to the public
uh they like to say sometimes sometimes
not that if the information is already
in the library it's in the public domain
you can then use that information but
how does the information once a person
creates it get into the library for that
they have really no consistent answer of
course our concern is that this covers
much more than guns it can cover just
about anything and the case happens to
be about guns maybe guns is what got the
government interested in the first place
but the concepts that the government is
trying to establish here would allow
them to censor just about any speech
related to any topic one of the most
interesting parts of this documentary
which I think will be new to most
audiences because they still think guns
were being distributed was the fact that
this is a discussion about the ability
and the legality of Distributing
self-made codee it is an issue of the
first amendment in the middle of your
making this documentary Cody was busted
for sex with an underage girl he met on
an adultsonly app what was that
experience like from a documentary
director's perspective it was it was
very rough and
trying um it's a strange moment when you
uh work with and are are allowed into
someone's life for such an extensive
period of time and you're building trust
and something horrible happens um and
you have to figure out where you
yourself stand um what information that
you can gather and also needing to do
your job and get things on film and
trying to figure out specifically for me
because I'm always creating in the terms
of I'm not putting myself onto this film
it's not about my opinions it's about
really trying to capture as adulterated
a moment as possible so not feeling like
a
vulture and that was a very intense it
was a very intense moment what was your
point of view on it if Cody had been and
this is in the film so people in the
audience I won't go into too much
description if Cody had been searching
out specifically a minor Cody will be in
jail right now period
um and because of a lot of information
that was brought up during during the
trial everyone does their own
investigations it was obvious that there
were lies and you can have as a person
issues with prostitution you can have
issu issues with the idea of Sugar
Babies you can have issues with uh you
know extreme differences of Ages Etc but
if the intent was not
to you know search out a minor and it
was
proved then you know at one point people
have to take
responsibility of what is happening and
I I personally and definitely believe
that
if the situation was different and if
the young lady did not have such an
extensive
history um they would have pushed harder
but uh also her identity would have
probably come out so there was a lot of
other factors this was not I think a
clean and cut case that maybe the
government or officials were hoping for
um that it would have been far
more the victim would have been far more
victimized if you will I noticed there
are several points in the movie where
Cody talks about the mental and physical
toll that constantly battling the
government has taken I'm going to be
screwed up because of the highs and
lows I'll spend every dollar that I have
suing the [__] out of
him
they want to put me in my place they
want me to know where the boundaries are
and they want me to know that they set
the rules as somebody spent a lot of
time with him what do you think
motivates him on a personal level to
take on that kind of Burden I mean I
think that's just part of who he is I
think he loves a challenge and at that
point what you're seeing what we just
saw in 2015 um the ghost Gunner had come
out he's tasting the first moments of
like his um payment services dropping
him of losing money he's getting legal
issues credit cards um Banks like it's
coming at him at all angles right but
there's definitely a part of him that
although the challenge is hyper
destructive to your you know cortisol
levels at at minimum right he loves it
at the same time I think people that
live this kind of like life of like
really uh challenging any kind of
government or control or building new
things they have to I think they have to
actually like it he talks about this
doomed historical figure James
Fannon Fannon 32 when he died shot in
the face he asked for three things so
says Wikipedia but also Lone Star I read
it in lar he asked uh that his facts be
sent back home that he'd be given a
Christian burial and that he'd not be
shot in the face right and uh so they
stole his [__] shot him in the face and
burned his
body I want the blessing of that Texan
Spirit of revolutionary action in what
we do and this was a young man like me
he went down to ignominy or something
he's not considered a hero he didn't but
he wanted to be one you know that's a
pretty hair raising bit to me because it
makes me serious L Wonder does Cody want
to be a martyr what do you think
originally when I used to talk to him
in3 to 25 he would say no but I do
absolutely think he wants to be
remembered but he doesn't want to be a
martyr he wants to be the winner so very
two very very different things um but I
think at that moment in that film he's
definitely in a place
where he
realizes that all his work might end up
being just him being
scalped if you will and Cody's very good
because he understands to him I think
something that's hyper motivational is
the symbol is the idea is the the the
connection and correlation to like
important parts of the past and you see
that in his you know his symbols that he
uses Etc um but no I don't think he
wants to be a martyr I think he wants to
be the winner at the end of the day and
a bit of a historical
figure that brings me to my last
question I've interviewed Cody several
times and it's always fascinating but he
can come across as fairly enigmatic he
sometimes speaks in riddles or highly
theoretical terms you spent so much time
with him you met his parents what are
your impressions of him as a
real person that are maybe different
from his Persona and what aspects of
that personality do you think have
driven defense distributed and this
larger project
forward he is that person Cody is
constantly reading and
absorbing he's he's thinking in terms of
philosophy and history it is his Jam
this is his motivation he loves all
these parallels that can be created in
today's society versus um past you know
past fights past Wars past uh ideas so
Cody I think actually correctly
represents him himself when he speaks in
these like high philos philosophical
terms this is completely his internal
motivations there's always something
theatrical when a a film or camera is
involved but this comes from a very
personal and centered place for him and
why do you think that that type of
Personality has been able to drive this
project forward so successfully he's
also extremely charismatic and uh
doesn't shy away from a challenge so you
have to be uh anyone creating something
in a space Not only has to be smart that
definitely helps but they have to
understand the game and then they have
to understand that to play it they have
to both be uh
entertaining
and uh quote unquote correct correct in
the form of your motivations and
possibly knowing the law which he does
right so the majority of things are
instigations to the law and that's why
he keeps being in the main frame it's
because it's constantly being on top of
what is happening in the Moment Like G
GPT and also um skidding across
everything that's in between legal and
non-legal right um so he's uh he
understands the terms of how to get a
message into the
mainstream and this is all very centered
to who he is as a person so I think
that's why it's so successful um and to
have anyone follow you especially in the
beginning or not even just follow but
work with you or Get Behind These like
kind of intense and possibly very
dangerous principles that could get you
in trouble you have to have a level of
um I guess charismatic integrity and one
thing you can dislike Cody but from the
very beginning he has not changed the
principles that have motivated him um
and that is what I hope the film also
captures but in far more in depth than
what anyone else has seen I think it has
captured that it's a compelling
documentary about a fascinating
political figure the movie is death
athletic it's available for purchase now
at death athletic.com and on Google
Amazon iTunes on October 21st Jessica
suce thank you for talking to reason
thank you for having me
Zach
[Music]